I work in something called string theory
that's what I do for a living in fact
that's my day job I'm the co-founder of
string field theory one of the main
branches of string theory the latest
version of string theory is called
m-theory m4 membrane so we now realize
that strings can coexist with membranes
so the subatomic particles we see in
nature the quarks the electrons are
nothing but musical notes on a tiny
vibrating string what is physics physics
is nothing but the laws of harmony that
you can write on vibrating strings
what is chemistry chemistry is nothing
but the melodies you can play on
interacting vibrating strings what is
the universe the universe is a symphony
of vibrating strings and then what is
the mind of God that Albert Einstein
eloquently wrote about for the last 30
years of his life we now for the first
time in history have a candidate for the
mind of God
it is cosmic music resonating through 11
dimensional hyperspace so first of all
we are nothing but melodies we are
nothing but cosmic music played out on
vibrating strings and membranes obeying
the laws of physics which is nothing but
the laws of harmony of vibrating strings
but why 11 it turns out that if you
write a theory in 1517 18 dimensions the
theory is unstable it has what are
called anomalies it has singularities it
turns out that mathematics alone prefers
the universe being 11 dimensions now
some people have toyed with twelve
dimensions at Harvard University for
example some of the physicists there
have shown that a twelve dimensional
theory actually looks very similar to an
11 dimensional theory except it has two
times double times rather than one
single time parameter now what would it
be like to live in a universe with
double time well I remember a movie with
David Niven David Niven played a pilot
who was shot down over the Pacific but
the angel
made a mistake he was not supposed to
die that day and so the Angels brought
him back to life and says oh sorry about
that we killed you off by accident you
were not supposed to die today so in a
great seam David Niven then walks
through a city where time has stopped
everyone looks like this and there's
David Niven just wandering around
looking at all these people that's a
world with double time David Niven has
one o'clock but everyone else has a
separate clock and these two clocks are
perpendicular to each other so if
there's a double time universe you could
walk right into a room see people frozen
in time while you beat to a different
clock that's a double time universe now
this is called F theory F for father the
father of strings it's not known whether
F theory will survive or not
however M theory in 11 dimension is the
mother of all strings and that theory
works perfectly fine so to answer your
question in other dimensions dimensions
beyond 11 we have problems with
stability these theories have are
unstable they decay back down to 11
dimensions they have what are called
anomalies singularities which kill an
ordinary theory so the mathematics
itself forces you to 11 dimensions also
because this is a theory of everything
there's more room in higher dimensions
to put all the forces together when you
put gravity electromagnetism on the
nuclear force together four dimensions
is not big enough to accommodate all
these forces when you expand to eleven
dimensions bingo
everything forms perfectly well